open and scary Oh with this mask that
I'm told is from Doctor Who
guys Halloween is just about here which
means it's time to scare up a spook
athon but did you know that some of your
favorite stars also starred in some of
your favorite horror franchises
it's too so grab your butcher knife put
on your hockey mask as we slowly walk
through they were in that horror edition
first up the two most famous horror
franchises and the two most infamous
early acting roles on our list Friday
the 13th and Nightmare on Elm Street
everybody knows that the first Friday
13th featured a young Kevin Bacon
meeting the business end of an arrow and
Johnny Depp's role in the original
Nightmare on Elm Street is also well
known to horror fans
but did you know that Johnny Depp
returned to the Nightmare on Elm Street
franchise that's right he played himself
in 1991's Freddy's dead the final
nightmare which wasn't the final
nightmare giving a public service
announcement to a young Breckin Meyer
this is your brain The Nightmare on Elm
Street franchise also featured early
roles from Laurence Fishburne and
Nightmare on Elm Street 3 dream warriors
and Oscar winner Patricia Arquette
probably the most prestigious actress to
be almost eaten by a worm monster so
Freddy and Jason both run out of gas in
the 90s and you know what that means
team him up in 2003 is inevitable
crossover Freddy vs. Jason but a future
star snuck into the long-awaited
showdown a young Evangeline Lilly
playing the key role of girl who stands
in the background and doesn't talk
that's when he comes for you in your
dreams this would be the second most
terrifying thing Evangeline Lilly
starred in just behind her weird one
eight hundred sinned
you don't need to go out and have a good
time just pick up your phone and call
language what am I wearing
a screen junkies t-shirt we'd be remiss
if we included the wasp without
mentioning the early horror role of her
crime-fighting partner ant-man that's
right before he was shrinking down to
microscopic levels Paul Rudd anchored
the 1995 cinematic classic known as
Halloween six the curse of michael
myers.slc
oh hey Star Wars is a thing that people
like odds are that more than one of you
are sitting there watching this video
while you got another window open trying
to get tickets to a 4:00 a.m. opening
night screening of The Force awakens
come on you know it's true everyone is
looking forward to the reunion of the
galaxy's premier couple han Solo and
Princess Leia but actors Harrison Ford
and Carrie Fisher have also done their
time on the horror movie circuit here is
him as Carrie Fisher and it typically
met a scene from scream 3 you know but
you look just like her
it's uncanny I was up for Princess Leia
I was this close so who gets it the one
who sleeps with George Lucas here's mr.
Han Solo Indiana Jones Harrison Ford
himself in a 1977 TV movie called the
possessed where it gets a little hot
under the collar wait
his career really caught fire nailed it
let's talk mr. blood diamonds himself
Leonardo DiCaprio he's made a career out
of turning in fantastic performances and
not winning Oscars but before all that
his very first film role was a young
Josh in the classic horror sequel
critters 3 I'm shocked the Academy
overlooked that performance you know I'm
shocked the Academy has never recognized
anything from the critters franchise
period uh maybe come down from your
ivory tower and recognize real art
academy critters speaking of young
actors here are a couple others that
graced landmark horror franchises JGL
Joseph gordon-levitt popped up in 1998
Halloween quasi reboot Halloween h2o as
Jimmy a precocious neighborhood kid who
ends up getting a skate to the face
Jimmy where are you going check out your
house no wait for the police
where's the fun in that huh Jimmy
and here's Elliot from et Henry Thomas
you remember him right playing young
Norman Bates and the little-known psycho
sequel psycho for the beginning okay
laughs I can't no Norman Bates stabs
someone you think they said oh that's
terrible
let's go to the other end of the age
spectrum and talk about everyone's
favorite golden girl America's grandma
Betty White
she is a bright shining beacon of hope
and optimism one of America's purest
treasures and here she is from the movie
Lake Placid telling someone to suck ur
dick if I had a dick this is where I'd
tell you the suckage and now to
America's other sweetheart America's dad
Tom Hanks here he is in his first role
ever as a bit of a know-it-all in the
1980 stalker flick he knows you're alone
most people do actually I mean like to
be scared like one wanna goober Tom
Hanks isn't the only Oscar winner to use
horror as a career launching pad 1994's
Texas Chainsaw Massacre the next
generation not to be confused with Texas
Chainsaw Massacre Deep Space nine stars
two of them Renee Zellweger and Matthew
McConaughey too well respected actors
who I'm sure are thrilled that this
footage will exist forever
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally whether you know him as Nick
Fury or mace windu samuel l.jackson is
such a big part of all of our lives and
he's the only guy on this list to get
eaten by a shark on film before he was
exploring the deep blue sea and flying
with snakes on a plane he popped up in
The Exorcist three and a dream sequence
that also featured and I wish I was
making this up Fabio can you hear us we
are attempting to communicate
come in please the living are deaf we're
saying they just ABR samuel l
[ __ ] jackson oh hell no you do
not record over one of the greatest
voices of all time enough is enough I've
had it with this mother and a dr in the
mother good movie
oh well that movies not very good anyway
now that was a good time so but movie
character are you gonna dress up as for
Halloween
is it gonna be Katniss Everdeen Captain
America Emily Blunt from Sicario let us
know in the comments section below best
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye fYI the guy that shot
the propane tank also plays Doug Stamper
on house of cards
which keeps my hopes alive that the show
ends with zombie Frank Underwood lording
over a nation of undead